hi I'm Katherine you're from the chess
club / never seen us before
today thank you and so high
our battalion and I played my game today
against Matt Larsen and i would like to
show you my game so i was playing the
white pieces and I solid with c4 just
English opening and see 593 96 g3 g6
Bishop to Bishop g7 so this is a pretty
safe opening for white and black to
develop into pieces and now I decided to
include this move aight the idea of
pushing before if you slice here 65 so
kind of public of walking a 50 and then
we can see sometimes on the b5 square
just i could be another type of three
5553 maybe six and so now again I played
some unusual move up a page for video
playing h5 and super bulking h6b should
be too
I j7 now there's an interesting what I
played with c1 so the idea is did not
black out castle because I've taken
bishop on h6 actually black have to file
an idea for you have to play here so
maybe Bishop g4 or maybe we should be
six so in the game it may be should be
six when I play it will be one just
waiting move and planning to play before
one someday books eh so no more moves I
guess and then now again we can't castle
because the h-60 on is hanging 27 1
selection by bishops I play dokie 1 and
d5 doesn't work because I just take take
if I bonus week so it will be six looks
pretty safe for the right now now he
wants to play the five so I baby for now
I'm not sure
94 not sure Bobby smooth maybe this was
gonna stay because actually wanna
exchange we change in the game the secon
another night jumpin be fun so now these
are those weaknesses on these six and v6
now he plays into f8 idea for me well so
now I just played before and obviously
that doesn't want to open the twin size
like with a 4-1 now I've saved my attack
on the Kings side it's an F for some
ideas right there so I've take this then
lukas ganging so we try to attack my
queen to bishop or care for a nice look
just giving the swing I'm ready to
change the Bishop Bishop takes Queen
takes and now it's very harmful left
okay because I'm letting f5 okay once
you play FF 6 but not a half deeper
study for the idea is it takes five
babies no coin edge right now I just
jump back with a knife maybe five one
here here's a bishop message for us
unless I callate because my queen is
hanging on is a good move
same again my thing now if it takes on
the phone interesting so he has to go
back it's time from the top and there FR
backh takes you five yes the prohibition
of this hanging now before here's the
move back to g7 the night takes on these
six I think may be screened 06 now in
five more defending the movie okay seven
yes among gospel for the games they
fired now the design because I have to
account for the claim and it's going to
be a mate actually it's like by the
knife maybe office that says we can't
imagine something like this just on